foreign
David is with us in Dallas to start off
this hour hi David welcome to the Ramsay
show
yes thank you sir for having me sure
what's up
yes so just quick context my wife and I
when we were engaged did FPU that was
six years ago we are now five thousand
dollars away from being debt free aside
from our mortgage way to go I'm just 5
000 yes thank you just five thousand
left of our of my student loans
um here's here's the thing we're pastors
here in Texas we are moving to Oklahoma
to be pastors of a church there and
what's awesome is part of the deal is we
have a parsonage so we will not have a
mortgage payment there
um and so my my Ultimate Dream is that
we are financially independent from the
church I love the church I would love to
one day not even have to take a paycheck
from the church and so what I'm seeing
is our expenses are staying the same our
income is actually going up a little bit
with this move and I would like to turn
my house in Texas uh into an Airbnb
property and hopefully even make income
to take one step closer to being
financially independent from the church
and so my question really is is that a
smart move or should I just sell my home
here in Texas profits I don't know the
way the market is right now I can maybe
profit 60 70k something along those
lines from what I've seen and so I'm
just asking you what may be the better
or best option is
um I love your goal
and I don't dislike your plan overall I
would I would sell the house and move
the money to Oklahoma pile up some more
cash and pay cash for your first rental
in your own backyard
airbnbs uh have
two problems that all the people that
talk about how much money they make with
them don't bring up or they have three
problems that people don't bring up
problem number one there's a ton of
hassle a lot of details a lot of work
involved in getting the people in
getting them out getting them cleaned
all that kind of stuff like uh probably
25x a normal a normal rental because
you'll have multiple renters in a single
month right
and so you've got you've got maid
service you've got a higher level of
Maintenance you've got a lot of work
involved in managing and messing with
them okay so a lot of hassle uh go ahead
so sorry interrupt can I just speak to
that I do have family here in Texas that
would be managing the property and so I
kind of have a little bit of a built-in
system which is a bad eye which is a bad
idea you're going to take you're taking
advantage of your family okay I'm
telling you Airbnb the hassle factor is
very high there's great money but the
hassle factor is very high so if you
want to do an Airbnb it needs to be in
your backyard problem number one with
Airbnb problem number two with airbnbs
is you have a lot of extra maintenance
people tear the crap out of your
property nobody talks about that that's
the Dirty Little Secret of airbnbs
you're constantly buying carpet you're
constantly buying paint and drywall
repair uh because they do not take it I
don't care how big a deposit you get or
how much screening you do it's not their
house and so you're going to have a high
level of repairs and maintenance which
is part of that hassle Factor the third
thing that nobody's talking about is
several areas uh are now passing zoning
prohibiting it right right and uh so if
you set your whole model up only on
Airbnb that you could have the rug
jerked out from under you if the only
way the deal works is Airbnb don't do
the deal because it might not be
available to you now if you want to run
the hassle for the extra money and run
the maintenance for the extra money
you'll make more money but it's a lot of
work so I would move the money to
Oklahoma whether you're going to do a
straight rental or whether you're going
to do an Airbnb because it's in your
backyard and you're going to lay your
hands on it and you are a man who
controls Destiny you don't ask your
first cousin to do it
yes sir yeah that's that's what I would
do if I were in your shoes but I like
your overall idea but let's just pay
cash for a rental and go that way
Christina yeah I've talked to a lot of
Airbnb owners and it kind of does feel
like a part-time job for a lot of them
and and you get six of them it's a
full-time job um
yeah and I agree that having your family
do that would kind of be taking
advantage of them especially if you're
not paying them if they don't get a cut
of that and if you start paying them
then the need for doing an Airbnb goes
away yeah exactly and there's just a lot
of of mental aspects of like I mean
there's a review system on there so even
with the maintenance even with keeping
your Airbnb up you want to make sure
that it's Top Notch because you want
those five star reviews if not you're
gonna have a tougher time booking people
and the list goes on and on it can
definitely be more of a headache and I
think your heart is with the church you
ultimately want to pour your heart into
the church that's why you want Financial
Independence and so that you can love on
people better and if you're stressed out
by this basic other part-time job that's
not going to be the best use of your
energy yeah I think it's a good move I
love your move to Oklahoma and you're
making more money just take your the
fact that you don't have a house payment
anymore pile it on top of that 60k go
pay cash for your first house then pile
all that rent up and or Airbnb money up
whatever it is and go pay cash go pay
cash for the second house and and go pay
cash for the third house and you end up
with five or ten properties you'll have
enough income coming in that you are
independent and then you can decide
um how you're going to serve the church
and what the financial arrangement of
that is you that gives you the option of
that and it does put you in a completely
different position
um in the church world for sure and I
love your heart and where you're talking
about going with it yeah and that's a
super exciting move congratulations with
all of that a new job new promotion and
not having to pay rent or a mortgage
that's outstanding so I think you're
going to be able to pile this cash up
quick
now it's going to put you in a really
really good position so I've got a good
friend that is a pastor and he started
at that age buying properties and he's
done exactly what he's talking about
doing he's become he's become he's got a
lot of real estate become wealthy and he
didn't steal the money from the church
and he didn't get overpaid by the church
he just managed his money well for
decades and has a bunch of paid for Real
Estate now and he's good at real estate
he's a pastor but he's good at real
estate and so uh you know he's managed
the properties well and he's you know he
it's like his little side job so to
speak his hobby he loves fooling with it
he loves messing with real estate like I
do and he's just done very very well so
he's many many years ahead of you uh
David and
um
he has done what you're right you know
he's put himself in a position that he's
independent from the church and so he's
publishing deals all that kind of stuff
he just he doesn't have to uh be unquote
owned by the local congregation unquote
and I it might even change a preaching a
little you never know
good well some people it would